cui bonjour je me présente michèle
audette de la nation innu et québécoise
bienvenue à une perle à la fois cette
paire si j'aimerais la donne et la
partager et l'enrobé de beaucoup d'amour
au 215 petit être lumière qu'on a
découvert récemment sur un ancien site
d'école résidentiel un pensionnat à
kamloops cet amour là aussi j'aimerais
la partager aux familles qui ont perdu
tous ces êtres charles
imaginons si nous avions écouté les gens
à l'époque
à cette époque là et sur une longue
période malheureusement à dire aux gens
je pense que mon frère je pense que ma
soeur je pense que mon enfant sera
enterré ici parce qu'il n'est jamais
revenu chez moi
pouvez vous m'aider à le retracer pouvez
vous m'aider à le retrouver
le statu quo le silence ou l'inaction
fait que on a encore une fois une preuve
qui fait mal
une preuve qui choque en découvrant tous
c'est petit être lumière
on nous dit aussi que c'est pas
seulement là bas qu'on aurait eu ce
genre de témoignage mais partout à
travers le canada
partout où des gens auraient dit la même
affaire et des écoles résidentielles et
des pensionnats il y en a eu beaucoup
partout mais mon québec alors je nous
encourage jeu nous encourage à nous
rappeler que l'histoire contient aussi
d'échapper de sombres lourd et difficile
et que ce n'est pas seulement aux
premiers peuples de porter s'échapper
blu-ray divisés mais à l'ensemble la
société canadienne et québécoise et à
partir de ce moment là vous comprendrez
que car jeudi
imaginons que nous sommes dans un conte
x comme aujourd'hui et ont fait cette
découverte est qu on sait aussi que les
enfants ont des droits et droit
international reconnu à l'international
des droits aussi au canada et au québec
ce courrier qu'on a une commission des
droits de la personne et des droits de
la jeunesse
nous n'avons pas respecté les droits des
enfants dans ce cas ci est la même chose
pour les par les parents aussi ont des
droits
nous n'avons pas respecté les droits des
parents ici et encore b - les droits de
la personne et des droits humains
vous allez me dire oui c'est dans un
ancien contact mais reste que les effets
de ces lois coloniales ou de ces
politiques coloniales on y vit encore
aujourd'hui en 21 et on les vit non
seulement de façon individuelle mais de
façon collective et ça et ça ça fait mal
mais en même temps beaucoup de gens vont
se lever relever les manches et proposer
des solutions proposer des mesures de
rechange
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas la magie de vous
proposer quelque chose qui va changer de
façon drastique
mais si je vous disais l'importance de
reconnaître l'importance de connaître ce
passé et qu'on pourra apprécier par la
suite de parler d'une réelle
réconciliation
ça sonne très chaud gars mais ce qui me
fait chaud au coeur aussi
c'est de reconnaître que des milliers de
gens qui vivent ce deuil en ce moment
font partie aussi d'un processus de
guérison tellement important et saufs au
point de négliger la guérison
individuelle et la guérison collective
alors si vous avez envie de faire partie
de ce mouvement de vérité de guérison
collective
je nous encourage à changer l'histoire
dans nos écoles je nous encourage à
demander à nos élus à nos gouvernements
à nos organisations
il faut qu construire
la virée histoire tout le monde un sens
encore une fois beaucoup d'amour pour
ses 215 petit être lumière et tout celui
celle qui sont encore enfouies dans des
fosses communes dans des sets de
sépulture ou dans des endroits qu'on ne
sait pas j'espère que vous allez rentrer
chez vous un jour auprès de vos membres
auprès de vos nations